the winner of survivor 42
marianne
that's five that's enough here we go
marianne it is my pleasure to officially
welcome you to the survivor winner
circle and i am so proud of you for
keeping the crown in canada
congratulations
how are you feeling i'm feeling great oh
my goodness i i i'm probably feeling the
same way you were feeling it's a surreal
experience you know it in your final
tribal council which i think was so
impressive i think there are so many
great moments you revealing your idol i
kept the only secret in this game i
actually after your vote tori had the
merch idol i can show it to you right
now and i told no one about it you can
see over here here's the idol that final
try but when everyone was just
continually talking to mike i'm like oh
my gosh they didn't even see me like i
guess i overplayed like i guess i didn't
think about it when people started to
talk to me and i was able to articulate
my game i'm like okay no i have a chance
i feel as if i have a chance again you
are the second black woman to ever win
in the franchise how does that feel it
feels amazing to know that i'm going to
go and be representation for people who
watch these shows but i think the bigger
picture of it is that when we have a
more diverse cast you get to have more
first like for example you're the first
filipino woman to win survivor
and over at the finale watch party in
santa monica which helped benefit the
charity give kids the world village
survivor alum discuss the importance of
diversity and i think going into the
future we're going to see just this
beautiful diverse array of
winners yes and i'm here for it and
listen i love it i think the game play
is a thousand times better and i love
the game of survivor and the fact that
they are incorporating fifty percent
bipac not just in front of the camera
behind the camera for me i live for it
we see omar who is muslim we have high
we have so much representation and to be
able to see that and have somebody like
a child like oh my gosh they look like
me or they sound like me or they do the
same thing as me or they're weird like
me um
just to have that representation is so
important for all different categories
of people